Hollywood star Johnny Depp is at the
High Court for the start of his libel
action against the Sun the newspaper
claimed the actor had been violent
towards his now former wife Amber Heard
Johnny Depp denies the claims our
correspondent and a Robinson is outside
the Royal Courts of Justice where
proceedings are underway
Adele what's happening
yes Johnny Depp is giving evidence the
first to give evidence in this libel
trial his lawyer has been questioning
him man he's now currently being
cross-examined by his ex-wife amber
heards lawyer his overarching case
though as we've been hearing this
morning and seen in his written skeleton
argument from his lawyers is that he
never committed any acts of violence
towards his ex-wife she alleges that she
was so that she was a victim of violent
acts and controlling and abusive
behavior over a number of years both
before and during their two-year
marriage he has said that he has never
done any of that the only time he's ever
grabbed her was to grab her arms to stop
her from hitting him in the face we are
going to be hearing about 14 alleged
incidents of abuse by Johnny Depp
against his ex-wife Amber Heard between
2012 and 2016 we've also been hearing
about recordings that the couple used to
make of their conversations to differing
accounts
Miz heard said that they used to record
their conversations because it would be
a way to remind Johnny Depp of how he
acted when he was on drugs and that it
would be a way to help him with his
recovery he denies this he said that
they recorded their conversations
because Amber Heard would often change
what she said and it would be a way for
him to go back and actually reference if
her words wouldn't match as he said he
also said that Amber Heard stroke hit me
is his words used in one incident a
witness statement that she'd written
agreed that she had been violent but
this she'd been trying to get him to
engage with her so as I said he's
starting to be cross-examined now amber
heards lawyer has been asking him about
the beginning
it's Fame and how he became addicted to
drugs over a certain amount of time he
said he had tried every drug known by
man he told the court and he talks about
in Pleasant lasat home as a child and
drug taking as an adult
he's just been asked as well by his by
amber herds lawyer who said to him you
are very charming now but there are
times when you're not he replied your
statement is quite blanket I'm well
aware there's been quite a lot of pain
from youth and the way that I was raised
we've also had a statement today
released by Amber Heard spokespeople
this is what she said amber never asked
for these proceedings to take place
amber obtained a domestic violence
restraining order against death back in
2016 and has tried to move on with her
life it's Johnny Depp who brought these
proceedings against a British newspaper
and has dragged her to the UK courts to
give evidence on some of the most
distressing moments of her life so we
this has been a case in ongoing for a
couple of years and we expect this
particular libel trial to last for three
weeks